In a written statement signed by 181 of the
nation’s top CEO’s, the Business Roundtable
signaled the end of shareholder primacy.
Customers, suppliers, employees, and communities
are now among the new stakeholders.
This raises several questions: How will firms
respond?
How will investment and shareholder returns
be affected?
Who wins in a conflict between a stockholder
and a stakeholder?
So far, equities markets have shrugged.
It’s hard to determine the effect on stockholders.
But, we can make predictions about which members
we expect this to impact the most.
On one hand are firms where stakeholder engagement
is already part of their corporate strategy.
For them, don’t expect much change.
On the other, are firms in competitive industries
where it’s profit maximization or nothing.
If they do anything other than focus on profits,
they won’t be in business for very long.
The most interesting cases are the firms in
the middle, who do not deal directly with
consumers, but for whom brand is important
– or firms trying to rehabilitate a negative image.
For them, expect changes to strategic decision
making.
What do you think about the Business Roundtable's statement?
Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.